um you obviously go from that to more of
like a real real co-host role with Colin
and I always tell people I've been a
huge Colin Cowherd fan forever because
I'm a radio nerd and I always would just
admire
his ability to go off without anyone to
bounce stuff off of
because like you could listen to him on
the radio like when I was like younger
and I'd be like this guy's it's just him
in there just like just talking and it's
like really entertaining which is really
hard as you know because you've been a
part of radio for so long I think you
guys had such a dope Dynamic on the show
as you kind of being his number two what
is it like because I'm I'm a huge Colin
coward fan what's he like as a guy and
just like what's it like working with
him because you guys had a great run
before you went to speak for yourself
and kicked your own thing off Colin's
the best he is I'm a radio nerd too so
you'll appreciate this he's a huge
prepper yeah so he does a two hour prep
show before the three hour show right so
there's a lot of prep he's very thorough
he wants to make sure he has the
graphics he wants to support what he's
talking about he wants to make sure that
he has the sound he wants to support
what he's talking about he wants to make
sure he has the statistics he's looked
up you know the historical stuff that
goes along with what he's saying he
really talks through all of the topics
so his ability to to you know stretch a
subject the way that you're talking
about and continue to have the
conversation with you the listener but
by himself it's crazy I mean his brain
works differently to be able to do that
anyway but it really also helps that he
preps a lot he doesn't like to waste air
time so sometimes sometimes it depends
on the show obviously but we'll do a
little banter back and forth whatever
about you know being in wine country or
whatever I'm going to Utah but it's
never
too long you know we don't let that
conversation be the conversation we're
having in the segment right he always
brings it back to okay what do we want
to get to here we're going to we're
gonna get to Aaron Rodgers here like we
can we can go a little bit off to make
sure that people know that we're human
beings but we got to talk about what we
planned on talking about he's very very
serious about the show he feels like
it's disrespectful to the audience to
not be prepared to do a show I love it
so that's what that's really what makes
him great and able to do such a big show
because three hours of content is a long
ass show for sure in our business that
is an insanely long show and he does it
as his show so he can do all of that by
himself if he needs to obviously uh for
you because you have your your solo
podcast I haven't done this podcast for
a while yeah but I have one for several
years but while you were doing uh the
coward show you had your own show right
um was the upside for you to leave the
Skip and Shannon show which is the
biggest show on the network to go to
Colin was it because you were able to
have like because you had your own
segment every day were you able to kind
of like you were able to get your
off you know yeah it was like the upside
or like what made you want to make that
move it was partly you know obviously a
different role in a more expanded
speaking role but now when I first went
to Colin it was still just you know the
news updates he'd bring me in here and
there but like it took a little time for
us to build up the muscle of him being
able to just lean on me when he needed
to like this is trust and chemistry I
had done the show a lot so I already
knew the Beats of the show because I was
filling on her a lot when I was doing
Undisputed so we already knew how to do
the show together but what the show was
going to feel like together just took a
little time and us doing it from home
during the pandemic actually really
helped us a lot because we just had to
talk that's all you had to do that's all
we had to do you have nothing else going
on yeah but for me you know my goal was
always to be in the role that I'm in now
and
it was important to me to always keep
growing in the business so I did two
years of Undisputed and I felt like I
had you know mastered that role and
there were you know I'd kind of Hit the
ceiling of how much better I was going
to get at that role and I was ready to
try something different and you know get
into a new challenge in a different type
of show so it was never that like I
didn't want to work with them or
anything like I love Skip and Shannon
and loved doing that show it was just
time for me to go to a new role do
something new yeah and similarly that's
that's why I made the jump to to speak
after Colin